she could be actively sucking my dick at
the bar while we're getting married at
the same time and dudes would still be
gone what are you doing later
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I'm so excited to
bring on fire during my show but the
host of the Doug Stanhope podcast
[Applause]
[Music]
the story is about relationships and I'm
pretending to read it out of my book
that just came out called digging up
mother a love story
foreword by Johnny Depp there's a chick
I lady I used to date in the late 90s
she was out of my league she was a
former child star one of People
magazine's 50 most beautiful people in
the world but not one of mine but she
was out yes she was out of my league but
we had nothing in common I don't know if
you remember the old coaching horses
it's now called the pikey is this it was
a shitty dive bar down on Sunset and
that's where I hung out I just lived
there slumped over with my seahorse
posture at the bar and this a
Lister chick she was hanging out with
the Kennedys and going to dinner with
Rod Stewart and I'm not invited on down
off at the Coach and Horses with
the schlubs and and the relationship
ended where she had she took some crazy
Flay I'm going to the Khan Film Festival
really can I come no and I know that she
has this bigshot global a list
ex-boyfriend over there that well I
can't come but you're gonna be with that
guy and she came back and the the long
version is in the book
Doug Stanhope digging up mother
available now on Amazon
she comes back and she I said so were
you with that guy and she goes yeah I
saw him and I said did you him
I just cornered her just Saturday did
you him and she said no but then
she continued on with but I gave him a
blowjob in his car you could have just
stopped after no like technically you
wouldn't be lying
you wouldn't be perjuring yourself you
didn't have to give me the blowjob in
the car I can't tell you who the guy is
but I'll tell you what he does for a
living he's the principal so I'll just
leave it vague that's not in the book
because the lawyers wouldn't allow it
now you know the rest of the story so I
go out on the you what you you you get
dumped like that and you want to get
revenge like I'm gonna go drop my
dick in at any vacant hole in town
but all my sewer grade options were they
don't tally up with the
principal I'm gonna at Denny's
waitress now yeah so I would they're
used to I don't know if it still exists
there was a club called the Union down
on Sunset and they did comedy so I went
down I had a show scheduled I show up
for an 8 o'clock show but they're late
they haven't unlocked the doors so
there's a group of people I can put this
book down now right probably the book
day so on outside of this club waiting
to go inside and and they're closed but
there's a group of people gathered and
there's a girl alone that was probably
to this day the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen in my life People
magazine wasn't there and she asked me
for a cigarette which triples the
attraction I got a girl that hot that's
not trying yeah she's not a Hollywood
it's an actual hot chick and she
bums a cigarette and I start some small
talk I'm not good at it but I what comic
are you here to see hoping she doesn't
say the wrong name cuz the last thing
that you want to hear is a hot
girl say she's here to see a shitty
comic that would just break your heart
so we have a repertoire we're talking
and we carry this inside the bar when
they open it and we sit down and she's
drinking whiskey straight and Matt
me or better for every beer I drank
she's a whiskey or two ahead of me and
this is a this is perfect and I
didn't tell her that I was a comedian or
that I was doing the show we're just
sitting there getting hammered and
drinking and I just waited till they
announced my name and then just hey I'll
be back in ten minutes just hold my seat
and I go up and I destroyed I
just wanna hang on oh yeah and then I go
up I destroyed it was like the scene
from anchorman where he plays the Jazz
[Applause]
and I crushed it was the best
kill move came offstage sat back down at
the bar beside her like nothing happened
so anyway where were we I'm not
smooth but I was if I can't close this
deal I don't deserve the paper
so we're shit-faced I bring her down to
the Coach and Horses what she loves
unlike the girl that dumped me yeah
she's all about dive bars and I
introduced her to all my friends there
and quickly because I don't want them to
steal her and we spend the night
together and at my apartment I wake up
to a non-committal but nice note with a
phone number
and rebound sometimes you cling to
that with ten times the zeal of the
relationship you're recovering from just
for fear of an empty bed I need you back
and it turns out she just she was living
three blocks behind the coaching horses
and she became a regular at my bar with
everybody hitting on her and I have no
claim
I her once I yeah yeah nice
didn't here's a note to you that
was fun
so I don't have a claim because she's
not my girlfriend but that's my rebound
and everyone at the bar is now
hitting on her now that she's a regular
and even if I did have claim to her no
one would she could be actively sucking
my dick at the bar while we're getting
married at the same time and dudes would
still be gone what are you doing later
and there was one night where I didn't
want to be aggressive with her I'm
hands-off but there was one night there
was a group of regulars back then at the
bar that I knew there's three levels of
regulars there's the guy that you hug
when you come in there's the one that
you high-five and then there's the one
you nod at and this one guy Lorca was
his name
Lorca he was a nodder he was a
third-level regular and he was this
brooding and our drunk he's a runny
little
and I when he'd get drunk he just he was
always he looked like he was always at
the edge of a fistfight and but he was
always sitting with Renee was the girl
the beautiful girl and I noticed he's
sitting with her a lot is she
him but I can't ask she's just a girl
I've but she's everything I need
I need you now I can't be alone with the
carnival in my head in my bed
there was a night where we ended up
playing cat and mouse where they were
sitting together and he'd get up to get
a drink and I'd sneak in and try to get
her over to my table or she'd get up to
take a piss and I'd strategically
located at end of the bar so when she
came out of the bathroom I hey I bought
you a drink come over this way that
guy come this way and it was a it was a
long night of drinking where I noticed
Lorca was leering at me and I've I've
seen him do this every night that I sit
at this bar but tonight I think is is he
trying to mad dog me is he or is he just
up but he's just staring at me
he'd come up to my table and lean on it
maybe he's just up and at that
point my friends Matt Becker and big fat
Ralphie may if you know big fat Ralphie
may they show up and I go I don't know
if I'm being paranoid but is this guy
trying to start with me like look
at how he's looking at me and they're
both more paranoid than me and big fat
Ralphie mate yeah dougie Stanhope yeah
yeah that guy's trying to start some
that dude man and I I but he
has done nothing overtly for me to like
step up to him and go hey you know that
the the weird look on your countenance
is disconcerting can you stop that sir
nothing to say but I'm sad that I'm such
a coward like do I have to man up to
this dude like he's done nothing I'm
sorry I'm sad that I'm so deluded by
this girl that I don't even know if I
have to be brave in the first place I
just I just want the girl so I just let
it ruin my night
he's staring at me and I'm staring at
him and I'm staring at her and I don't
know how to close the deal so at
one point they called last call
you're welcome to be invited to get the
out of our bar we all funnel out
and I'm still trying to figure out how I
can close the deal or if I'm gonna have
to fight it dude I don't I don't
so we walk out of the bar Ralphie may
Matt Becker and I we take a left to go
to the car and this dude Lorca runs out
behind us to try to cross Sunset
Boulevard in a hurry and he gets killed
by a speeding car
literally knocked him out of his shoes I
didn't expect the story to end like that
either Thanks
[Music]